James Lofton will join us he played in
three Super Bowls hall-of-famer
and good to see again man nice - nice to
be here I'm amazed at how many cameras
there are well that's their trying to
get one that'll capture the good side of
me and they still haven't found one I
think we got 12 cameras in here by the
way you got a problem with my blouse
that I have on today no I like it
good it's very fashionable thank you
thank you
do they sell men's clothes thank you
thank you help me with this I will
Minnesota Minister super bowl did the
bills party with Prince I don't know
that that was the first I'd heard of it
you'd never heard I never heard of it
would you tell me if that were the truth
yes I would hey it's been 25 years ago
but you would remember being with Prince
oh I would remember I didn't get to
party with Prince did you hang out with
more stay in the time instead of I did
not but I would have loved to them yeah
yeah I what I remember about Minnesota I
remember an ice sculpture so you go to
the Super Bowl you're outdoors and
there's an ice sculpture that's not
melting yeah because it's so that's your
big memory of that's my big takeaway do
you get a Hall of Fame ring yes it's
it's in my bag over there I forgot to
forgot to put it on wait wait you're
it's in your bag yeah it's in my bag the
one that that guy just ran what are you
doing here okay so they're gonna bring
it up okay so you have a Hall of Fame
ring you see I have to because we got
one initially and then later on the Kay
Jewelers yeah gave a second one which
they call now the ring of excellence so
and it's it's big and it's so big that
it's it's hey where'd it go I even carry
it around in this but why do they make
these rings so gaudy because no they're
not so that they fit somebody who weighs
300 pounds
yeah but you don't I don't so I need the
200 pound ring but that thing but you
know what I think they wanted it to be
comparable to the Super Bowl rings and
before it just had one little stone in
the middle and it looked like a ring
from the first Super Bowl say you know
and so this is this is comprable people
ask me say Cydia is that a Super Bowl
ring and you go no it's from the Pro
Football Hall of Fame
you're just reluctant to say you know
I'm even reluctant to wear it you just
you tell you look really uncomfortable
where you know wow that thing is did you
rather have that or now you're super
inside of it it also tells which player
I was to go into the Pro Football team
so I was player number 220 yes and
that's that's kind of neat and in our
jacket see it even has that sewn in my
jacket so that's that's a fun thing it
looks good on you you should have been a
professional football player would you
rather have this or a Super Bowl ring
yes I think I would have liked to have
won one and also gotten this yeah it's
still this much that's how much we lost
by Scott Norwood's ball just didn't come
back in you know how when you you hit a
draw yeah look and he normally would hit
a nice soft draw and that ball just
stayed straight when you guys jumped up
and down what were you thinking on the
sidelines I was thinking because I knew
that was his range 47 yards late air is
kind of heavy that that was gonna be a
long kick for him and he probably if it
was a straight kick he would have made
it from 53 or 54 so he hit it really
well it came off his foot well but it
just never drew back in and he never
kicked again no he kicked the next year
for us no he did never kicked again you
see you just rewrite history he walked
off the field we never saw offense to in
Minneapolis to Nova funny story night
today's my anniversary my wife and I
have been married 36 years and I
shouldn't I shouldn't tell this story
about her but she and a girlfriend
good party with prints on a regular
season game when I was playing with the
Green Bay Packers well though they ended
up at the club and they ended up behind
the ropes and wait I guess they were
purple ropes at the time and so well
what else you got there
that that that's all I've heard you know
you there are more tight-lipped about
that story you know he's uh James Lofton
the whole favor joining us here were you
guys ever briefed debrief before he went
and met with the media I know media day
is different now Super Bowl week were
you ever debriefed on what to say not
say and not not really no no
Marv levy never did that bill Pollan who
was our general manager never came in
and did that and I think they said just
go have fun
Darryl Talley had the the best response
he was our linebacker and kind of you
know a guy who would say just about
anything and we had beat and I think
somebody in the AFC Championship game
and it was either the second or third
time we were going back and he's America
get ready we're coming back again so you
know he had fun with it a lot of players
had fun with it but no it won't be
achieved to get you know somebody going
four years in a row minutes it was truly
remarkable what I always hated is that
you guys were viewed as losers because
you lost four Super Bowls the Vikings
lost four Super Bowls to get there is
what was amazing and I think that people
forgot that and it's held against
players trying to go to the Hall of Fame
a little bit a little bit it's funny I'm
a Hall of Fame selector this year Oh and
so I have those 15 plus three guys that
it's funny I think about them just as
much as I think about my children every
day you know a thought goes through my
head about you know what I'm sure it is
a lot of pleasure it's it's like you're
the bouncer at that Club where Prince is
you know and people are lined up and
you're going oh not now and then
somebody comes out you can go in you can
go in and you feel bad for the people
who are out there standing in the cold
there Wayne and but how do you we often
discuss this we'll say somebody's a Hall
of Famer you'll just say the name
yeah and it's yes or no can you do that
yes I think I had one of the selectors
years ago said not yet and so what does
that mean not yet because you you
look at the list and you go these guys
these eleven guys the Hall of Fame
worthy but I can only let fight there's
only room for five people so you've got
a minivan or say you've got a two-seater
and you've got to take one of the dance
with you okay well which one and you
can't but you can't put one in the trunk
either you can only have room for one on
this trip so you take one I'll take Poli
oh wait were you asking me to pick
worthy they're also worthy no yeah no
they're not Terrell Owens Hall of Famer
well see I I can't reveal that yet I
could I'm but it's d1 I I am better at
this than I am at having to pick the
game because it for the game I'm working
the Patriots sideline so I can't say
which team I want or I think is gonna
win so I remain neutral I'm like
Switzerland in this regard is Owens is
Owens a teammate factor does that factor
into his whole for me yeah no you don't
care what he was like as a teammate I
don't because you're talking about
reports just like you asked me about did
we party with Prince I don't know before
you know it doesn't factor in what he
did on that I think it's fifty three and
a third by a hundred yards and 10 yards
of endzone he was phenomenal he was
phenomenal you were gonna work the
Patriots sideline for the cessful how
four forthcoming yeah I know what are
the Patriots wait what what do they tell
you one what information can you get not
a lot but but what you're looking for
you kind of looking for backstories
what's kind of funny is when Malcolm
Butler intercepted the ball against the
Seattle Seahawks I was the second person
to interview him I'm standing behind
Michele Tafoya and she's doing TV and I
have this look on my face like I smelled
something that wasn't favorable and my
family took a screenshot of it and they
passed it around everybody and then I
interview him and so I saw him this year
and for Sunday night game I think when
they played Seattle yeah I said I said
do you remember me he comes I see you at
the games you're James Lofton I said
yeah but I was the guy who interviewed
you right after you intercept is the
past I said he said I you know just it
was a whirlwind so you get little
stories like that and you get to creep
in a little bit
so now you've gotten past you know
you're working the game and maybe you
can ask him about coverage on Julio
Jones during the week or whatever but
they're not terribly forthcoming but
that's okay but you face Bill
Belichick's defense when Belichick yes I
did so he will and it's so funny I've
talked to him and he remembers the
coverages that they were getting ready
to throw out and you know routes that we
ran and the combinations and it's it's
amazing but he takes away your best
weapon was yes but but Thurman Thomas
had a great game yeah so you didn't take
away their best your best weapon I don't
know if that was the theme at the time
hanji Reid got banged around a lot
though if you remember that he really
took a pounding in that ballgame who
would you put in first you got one vote
you got a 2-seater oh okay Belichick or
breeding ooh
well I don't think coaches have to wait
the five years when they get out dudes
let's assume you're making an assumption
yes we are béla checker Brady I think I
might go with the player as opposed to
the coach first why cuz I'm a player
play uh which offense do you like better
the the last two weeks I've seen the
Atlanta Falcons in person so I've done
both those games for Westwood one sports
I get five dollars and really impressed
with Matt Ryan and something he said to
me before the Seattle Seahawks game on
the field I asked him about Julio Jones
and I asked him about was he a needy
receiver did he come back I'm open he
said no he doesn't do that and and that
to me that's such a
compliment and when I watch the little
play and when he has a complimentary
route he runs it just as hard as when
he's the primary receiver and to me
that's impressive that says a lot about
him on the other hand what would what
would concern you about Antonio Brown
with his personality not not his
personality and all that just kind of
kind of his his size because he can be
you you can get really physical with
them if you have helped over the time
you don't worry about this you know what
he did with Facebook laugh or any of
that stuff just a little disappointed
but what it is is as the head coach you
were always faced with new challenges
you know Bill Belichick is real funny
you know he doesn't he's not in the
snapchat or FaceTime or you know he
makes fun of it yeah but you have to be
on top of social media to know what the
players are about to do not what not
what they were able to do last week so
the concept of somebody putting out the
the postgame press talk that you're
having with the team live it's not
something you think about you think oh
don't record this but you're not
thinking I'm gonna get hit on this live
so you don't care that's an issue and
now it's been resolved yeah I don't
think so I think it's a big issue I
think it's a bigger issue with okay yeah
I really do I think he's well I can't
imagine having that many followers and
if you do I guess there's the way you
can make money off of it you know with
my 25 followers I can't make a lot of
money off them yeah but he's getting you
know high six-figure deal have Facebook
to do that though that's and this after
a win and you're not even listening to
your coach yeah to me I think there's a
big but you're gonna record it and
listen to him later yeah of course yeah
he's James Lofton we don't know if he
partied with Prince or not I would have
liked to though no your wife did though
yes he did
happy anniversary I know great see again
James came here thank you for coming by
yeah alright the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
you